welcome back to rockstars i'm eric boss
and doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness released even more trailer
footage this spot titled reckoning with
even more mysterious imagery and audio
clues posing some dark implications for
what's in store so i'm gonna break down
all the new stuff because otherwise you
folks would do to me would want to do
that ultron century and this video is
sponsored by story blocks more on them
later let's take a look
this universe
[Music]
[Music]
your reckoning is long overdue
[Music]
whoa definitely saw a lot of new stuff
in there actually when i first watched
it this morning i was like new new
new new new and then kelly was like you
said new more than six times there's
definitely a video in there and then i
was like i am so sorry this is your
world now too so let's start with the
marvel studios title card we actually
saw this with the december trailer too
but it's depicted as split glass
reflecting different past eras of the
marvel title logo including the version
that would play in front of marvel
titles from other studios like the sony
spider-man movies and the fox x-men and
fantastic four films in the netflix
daredevil universe series as well and
now that we know professor x from those
fox x-men movies is appearing in this
film this looks like a deliberate design
choice to evoke those alternate
universes and to show how every past era
of the mcu is about to get broken wide
open you can also see how this prism is
broken five ways reflecting the five
appointed star portals that america
chavez kicks through realities i also
like how it now comes with this weird
sound effect
yeah so much synthetic chaos suddenly
cut into silence like the mcu past is
part of some matrix simulation glitching
out of control until finally getting a
hold of itself and straightening out
like it's a trying to hide all this
chaos from us because i think this movie
is ultimately going to reveal that all
the mcu we've been living with this
whole time has been a gaslighting
simulation on us and they're finally
gonna admit that the true marvel
universe should have mutants in a
fantastic four and deadpool in it that
all this time we have been lied to
calling me a liar now the voice we hear
is actually a line from the ancient one
in the 2016 film her multiverse lecture
to stephen strain as she sent him
spiraling through various surreal
dimensions for the first time
this universe is only one of an infinite
number
worlds without end some benevolent and
life-giving
others filled with malice and hunger
dark places
where powers older than time
ravenous
and waiting
who are you
in this vast multiverse mr strange but
now it is mordo's voice finishing the
quote this vast multiverse suggesting
mordo might be directly quoting the
ancient one in this scene as part of his
speech to strange giving strange a bit
of deja vu stephen strange
your reckoning is long overdue actually
back in 2016 that was the first
utterance of the word multiverse in the
mcu and we later learned that the
benevolent and life-giving reality that
he floated in in that moment with all
the prisms was meant to be the quantum
realm or at least the gateway to it that
scott lang passed through and the one
filled with malice and hunger the dark
dimension this is the kind of thing that
mortar supreme now refers to by
strange's reckoning because also in the
2016 film that mordo warned strange that
meddling too much of the time stone as
strange continued to do in that film and
an infinity war nand game that meddling
would lead to this kind of reckoning
temporal manipulations can create
branches in time
unstable dimensional openings
spatial paradoxes time loops you weren't
manipulating the space-time continuum
you were breaking it
we do not tamper with natural law
we defend it and then later he warned
you still think there will be no
consequences strange no price to pay we
broke our rules just like her the bill
comes
to you always then a familiar shot of
defender's strange saving american
chavez from the ribbon monster but it
has now recolored his protective sphere
spell from golden orange as sorcerer
eldritch magic normally is to the color
white and you can see how behind him the
white sorcery is reflected in the shield
that restrains the monster interesting
because we just saw a little example of
some other white sorcery used in moon
knight episode 3 when osiris threw his
avatar restrained konchu in mark's body
from striking arthur hero we will not
tolerate violence
in this chamber now other times we've
seen sorcery used by these egyptian
deities like when harrow used ahmed
staff to summon the jackal or to break
the sarcophagus or when the yinya turned
konchu into a stone who shopti to punish
him the sorcery in that case was all
purple so maybe white is the color of
purely defensive spells that do no harm
merely peacefully restrain the attackers
from doing harm against others
essentially the mcu spell of hey hey
take it outside you two now one of the
tools we use here at new rockstars to
make our videos better is story blocks a
storyblocks membership is essential for
any creator and thanks to storyblocks
for sponsoring this video they have a
huge demand-driven royalty-free library
full of 4k and hd footage after effects
and premiere pro templates music images
and sound effects all to bring your
stories to life we have got the
unlimited all access plan which gives
you unlimited downloads for the over 1
million assets in their library choose
from one of their flexible subscriptions
that scale to give you all the content
and tools you need to focus on creating
not worrying about budget and if you're
a member of a large creative team a
marketing agency or a media organization
their enterprise license has your back
with comprehensive coverage for your
entire company that enables you to
distribute wherever whenever so go to
storyblocks.com
new rockstars now or click the link in
the description to check out their
unlimited all-access plan today then
there's a new shot of strange turning to
look over his shoulder at christine
palmer's wedding and then a rapid fire
montage of these eye close-ups there's a
scarlet witch wanda with her eyes
glowing red reminding us of the final
shot of one division episode six the
moment she vastly expanded the walls of
her west view hex warping reality and
the territory around it wanda may now be
doing something similar but to all of
reality and then another quick shot
shows i think it might be wanda's eye
again or maybe strange's eye they both
have green eyes and it's kind of hard to
tell since it's just three frames but
you could see some ghostly form
reflected within that eye there was a
similar shot of wanda's eye in the
february trailer showing the two holding
cells reflected within but here it looks
like someone pumping their arms up over
their head to the upper right i don't
know it could be america chavez but it
also looks a bit like that captain
marvel maria rambo variant at least
that's who we think that is who mwanda
fights in the illuminati citadel then
there's this awesome match cut of
strange observing the melting city that
takes us to the more utopian new york of
supreme strange with this big dumb
statue in front of his sanctum and you
can see even more vegetation covering
every surface as well as this grid
structure bursting with colorful foliage
one pedestrian passes us wearing tidy
futuristic fall wear and i love this the
traffic lights have been replaced with
this green sign with x's and then the
street signs also no words just a
five-row dot arrangement kind of like in
this reality even the printed english
language was replaced with something
automated technology might be able to
scan more easily it all just reads it's
super efficient and i love it i love all
the weird little details here but then
my favorite shot of this promo a
dramatic new image of wanda or wanda's
more violent variant in her attack on
this illuminati citadel proving the
origin of her dark stains on her face
and clothes this fluid gushes from the
severed head of an ultron sentry which
she continues to strangle as it bleeds
out probably to send a message to the
others until just crushing it this
definitely evokes wanda's coldest moment
from age of ultron when she ripped
ultron's robot heart from his chest and
just let it bleed in her hand then
there's a new shot of gargantua's
chasing america chavez down the street
flipping over cars like the guy thinks
he's doc ock or something oh my god
garganto's doctor octopus variant could
burn kidding but again it is really the
sound effect added here that i'm most
interested in
[Music]
stephen strange what the hell even was
that blippi poppy sound
what is this tivo
again it just sounds technological like
a simulation glitching out now the last
new shot shows us christine palmer in
her variant blue attire in this similar
pink colored setting as the place that
they open the hatch to to recover the
blue glowing book that i've been
speculating could actually be the book
of vashanti and the fact that that hatch
is opened with the watch christine gave
strange in the 2016 film suggests that
this watch which we keep seeing over and
over again in trailer imagery can be
very very important to the film and
perhaps a kind of constant artifact that
exists in every reality because we
learned in what if episode 4 that
christine's death was an absolute point
perhaps in the live-action mcu this
watch could have some sort of absolute
point status to it hey a reminder to
check out our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow new rockstars subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you want
thanks for watching
[Music]
foreign
[Music]